[Applause]
get it out get it
out inside in Five Seasons this is never
happen
we have had Rowdy audiences but in Five
Seasons you win that is you all get an
award um that was insane congratulations
on all the Grammy
Noms it's going to keep happening well
congrats on yours too I know I was
telling I was telling her
backstage I was telling her backstage
the win for me is is literally who I'm
nominated with like that's the win for
me I was telling her like I was to see
like who's in the same category and I'm
like and everybody is so good and the
category were both in I was like oh my
God I was so that's the win for me to be
like amongst your peers that you're just
like oh my God like that those are
people I would collaborate with I listen
to I love like that's the win for me so
nice to be like included in such a
wonderful gr of people yeah absolutely
what what I don't what's your most
meaningful Nom was it your first one
that was for sour that record yeah yeah
I got nominated for sour which was so
cool this year I actually got nominated
for um best rock song for
B which is so cool that's an amazing
thing I hear on your so I'm on tour you
saw me or they're right here they're in
ear we call them in ear but you can
decorate them and I go gold sparkly 70s
um but you have photos on yours I didn't
know you could do photos yeah you can
put photos no one told me this yeah you
put photos of your kids photos of anyone
those are mine Ed that that's my that's
my baby like that's my thing yeah that's
Twi that's Edward Colin on my in
ear yes um
purple lavender I like it yeah he's my
Guiding Light on tour you know to have
to have my lucky charm yeah love him
what's on your in ear now my in ear now
for this guts tour I'm I'm going to get
a new face every tour so taking
suggestions for the next one maybe I'll
put you on my next one aim for like
something random like Betty White like
something random right but this year
that makes you happy totally oh it's Kim
katrol yeah it's Kim
katron I love that it's Kim katrol from
from Sex in the City Samantha from Sex
in the City she's my favorite and she's
like drinking a little martini and I
thought it was why not why not you know
what that says celebrate every time you
put your in yours in I like it I think I
did know you could do photos do you have
Rue do you have Rue on yours okay her
dog I was like maybe I have seen photos
I know I need to be cooler I'm Inna aim
higher okay in honor of her album guts
we are hosting a gutsy hour everyone in
the audience has taken a very gutsy
chance and many have Olivia to thank for
inspiring them to do so it's weird cuz
you don't think you're going to have
that kind of impact on someone but it
really does music is so magical like
that so why why guts why that for your
title yeah I just always love the word I
think it has so many interesting
meanings like you know it means bravery
um spilling your guts means like telling
everyone your dirty little secrets which
I feel like is just what I do in my
songs yep um amen yeah so it's just a
really powerful word and um I like a
four-letter word you know me too you
know yeah Gotta Love a four-letter word
every now and then uh so yeah just
became the title I love that I love all
the separate kind of ways you can take
it as well yeah will you tell us about
some lyrics we have we pulled some for
okay because there's so many good ones
um and Lacy Olivia writes and I despise
my jealous eyes and how hard they fell
for you yeah I despise my rotten mind
and how much it worships you I mean that
last
line I despise my rotten
mind just worships you I'm like that who
has not felt you have a very poetic way
kind of like Alanis like you have a
poetic way of like wording things but
they're so relatable but it's so poetic
wow yeah where were you what were you
thinking that um yeah I I like emo
that's all right too me too um I took a
poster class actually at USC this year
last year and um I wrote that I wrote a
poem called Lacy for one of the
assignments and I really liked it I'm
like I'm G turn into a song so that's
sort of where that have time to go to
college I
know I know that train out I know I just
took one class I was going to the studio
some days and then I'd go to college and
like it was fun it was fun that's so
cool I love that you did that it's
always cool to like progress and grow
yeah yeah always want to stay curious
you got like a great song out of it damn
all right um so next in all- American
Olivia says I am they like it I am light
as a feather I'm as stiff as a board I
pay attention to things that most people
ignore so first of all what do you know
about that game that's the game I played
when I was a kid yeah did youall do that
light ASA done okay did did it work well
here's the thing there's like 15 of you
around the body with your fingers and
you're all doing it at the same time
that's what we did so of course we're
all going to lift them I mean these are
powerful fingers like it was all of us
and we're all like tiny at the time we
were playing it that's true well my mom
used to tell me about doing that at
sleepovers so that's how I knew the
light board thing and I was always
fascinated by it I'm like that seems
impossible like I need some physicist to
like explain it to me but it's I think
it's just literally we we want it to be
magical but really it's all of us just
underneath lifting the person up we're
like how is this
happening yeah but I always thought it
was a a really interesting phrase and so
I've been trying to fit into a song for
a long time so I thought it was an
interesting way to describe like it
seems kind of impossible I as a feather
stiff as a board so I thought it was a
good way to describe kind of the
impossible standards that are set for us
as women so it's just kind of yeah I
love I love that you take something that
everybody knows too and you twist it in
his that's very smart well we have an
audience full of people who have been
inspired by Olivia to take some gutsy
chances but before we hear them um I
feel like we should share ours I'll
share I was kind of sharing a little bit
of mine in the break but I I get tattoos
um well not all of them but a lot of
them are when not great things happen um
and I do it because I like the reminder
that I made it and like and and it some
sometimes things seem so big in your
world at that moment and you feel like
you're not going to make it and then you
and so usually that's when I get the
tattoo um one of my favorites is on my
middle
finger um yeah and it says DC and it's
because somebody made me feel and I
don't know I hope you never experienced
this or haven't but because I do think
we've progressed a little in this
industry but um yeah people can be very
mean I mean they can be just vicious and
it's you know if you're not successful
how they want you to be are doing what
you want and it's usually their
shortcomings sure and I mean just
someone was so vicious and I was so
tired of sitting in a room where men
just made me feel like and then I was
like you know what nope I actually had
the guts to finally say and I was in my
20s you know and I started at 19 so I
was it took a minute but I finally said
like you know what I was like actually I
think this is about you and I think this
is about and I just totally said
everything I've ever wanted to say in
that moment so that's one of my favorite
wow that's beautiful yeah I hope you
don't go through that that's one of
yours oh my gosh my gutsy story after
that beautiful mine's going to sound so
silly I don't know no it won't make it
lighter okay okay I was a little heavy
for daytime yeah yeah daytime you know I
was thinking coming up here um because
we're at 30 Rock we're in New York yeah
what the second time I ever performed in
my career was on SNL and I was 18 years
old I was so which is incredible I mean
what an honor but I was terrified yes
and it's so late it's so late yes for a
vocalist and it's so live uhhuh um for
the name and um I just remember being
terrified and being in my dressing room
and being like I don't know if I deserve
to be here this is terrifying but did it
anyway and I that that was Brave of me
but not not quite as beautiful whatever
don't do that that is very brave I'm
done ASL it's a little ner yeah today I
brought with me this key it's the key to
my first Department that I moved into
all by myself and I have a disability
called cerebral paly which makes it
limits my Mobility it's definitely been
nerve-wracking scary it can be
frustrating at times and it makes me
think about Olivia's song Ballad of a
homeschooled girl because in that song
she talks about feeling insecure anxious
after growing up sheltered and I
definitely relate to that but when I
look at this key it makes me feel like I
made the right decision and I feel proud
all right welcome back everybody I'm
here with the one and only Olivia
Rodriguez Olivia's album is called guts
which celebrates the gut Etsy choices we
all make and that was Michaela Lee who
just got her first apartment in a new
city she brought her key as a symbol
which is so beautiful in fact everyone
brought something that represents a
gutsy moment in their lives before the
show we invited a few fans like Michaela
Lee to share their stories on camera
what they didn't know is that Olivia and
I were watching in another room so check
this out I've been dying to have Olivia
on my show her new album is called guts
and we're finding all these fans that
have these really amazing gutsy stories
and we want to surprise them with with
her they're going to lose their mind so
here we go let's do it this is the
studio and he you're going to be talking
straight into the camera hi my name is
Michaela Lee and this is my gutsy story
today I brought with me this key it's
the key to my first Department that I
moved into all by myself I have a
disability called cerebral paly which
limits my Mobility growing up I wasn't
sure if or when I would be able to live
independently and it makes me think
about Olivia's song ballot of a
homeschooled girl because in that song
she talks about feeling insecure anxious
after growing up sheltered and I
definitely relate to that she's helped
me through so much with her music we
wanted you to meet
her you are amazing you are so
incredible I'm so happy to meet you
thanks for coming thank you for you're
incredible thank you so much B getting
your own apartment in the first place
it's a terrifying thing oh my God my
gosh I'm excited about this we wanted to
surprise like people that felt like
empowered like I felt empowered by
listening to gutsy I'm 41 and I felt
empowered so it's an incredible thing to
connect with an artist like that but I
feel empowered listening to your story I
think that is so incredible and I I
admire you so much for that that's not
an easy feat I'm so proud of you thank
you so much for coming with so nice to
meet you and thank you for telling your
story it's so beautiful don't worry
about the cameras this is very normal hi
my name is Jasmine and this is my gutsy
item it is a board in pass so I met a
guy through work we hit it off
immediately and he met my whole family I
met his whole family and I was like this
is love this is it and so we were long
distance for a minute and I decided I
was like I'm going to spend my own money
and I'm going to go out and visit him so
I go out to visit him and The Vibes were
off it was very weird there's a girl
there she's driving us around I'm very
confused um so I go home I'm like I'm
humiliated um so I'm out with my girls
and I run in to the entire family and
they're like oh no you know he actually
has a girlfriend and I said who and they
said it was the girl that was driving
your rounds and I said oh okay good so I
was thinking about Olivia I was thinking
about her songs and I said I too want to
meet his mom and tell him her son sucks
so that's exactly what I did I would say
thank you for really singing my inner
teenager and really bringing her out and
letting me me
too oh my
God that is the craziest story oh my
gosh how are you
I'm good to meet
you I'm so sorry that happened to you
it's okay it literally doesn't even
matter ever ever again you're a hell of
a gutsy woman you made it through um
thank you you're going to be out there
with us we just wanted to surprise oh my
God we want it was soce to oh my God
you're so amazing you're so amazing this
is the best day ever oh God thank you
that was
amazing what the
actual hi my name is Cassie and this is
my gutsy story I brought a receipt from
the dining hall at my college where me
and my now husband Chase used to always
get milkshakes together and I really had
feelings for him but I thought we can't
date I come from a religious Jewish
background and family they wouldn't
approve but I cannot let this person go
who cares about me so much like how can
I let that go and I eventually told my
family and that was probably the
gutsiest thing I've ever done it was the
most scared I've ever been I think it
all worked out eventually they came
around they loved him now we just got
married this September 2 days after guts
was release her music means so much to
me I feel like so proud as like an older
fan she's such a great role model to so
many people they so
sweet that was so nice you're so
generous and first of all you are not an
older fan I am an older fan that was the
most beautiful story thank you for
sharing that I'm so honored to meet you
right now
Olivia you're the coolest I'm so proud
of you you are doing such amazing things
and I love your music so much so many
girls out there people
of all genders and ages are so lucky to
have you in this industry to see what
you do for them and your vulnerability
and your passion and I'm just like so
honored to tell you this oh my God you
are so eloquent I've never that when I
meet people I love congrats on your
wedding thank you so much oh my God your
like a picture I would would we have to
we have to take a picture to show him
I'm going to let her get one alone that
way you don't have to crot
me yeah
Jasmine Michaela and Cassie are all here
today everybody so
Michaela M I'm going to start with you
so what what were you thinking when she
tapped on your shoulder oh my gosh so
shocked so surprised I was like what's
going on I'm still in shock and I was
telling these lovely people that I'm not
crying right now but probably when I go
home I'll like listen to guts and cry
because even before guts came out like
sour helped me through my first
heartbreak and your vulnerability allows
me to be vulnerable so thank you so
much what are you I imagine like with
this album you've had so many fans come
up to you and tell you kind of their
gutsy moments like what what does that
mean for you like how does that affect
you it's so incredible I mean also when
I put out sour it was kind of pandemic
era so I didn't really get to actually
interact with people who were listening
to the music um so it's really special
to get to meet you guys and hear your
stories I I love it so much thank you
guys for coming it means the world to
me well Olivia six time Grammy nominated
album that's why I said six time guts is
available right now wherever you get
your music you got to get it it's so
[Music]
[Applause]
good thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home